STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the session about
Security At Scale at Google,
where hopefully, I will
be able to give you
an idea of how we approach
security at Google, Google
WIDEOUT, at Google Scale.
Just in terms of defining
the problem space,
the way we think
about security is
protecting our users
and their data.
And that is admittedly
a very broad scope,
but that's exactly
how we think about it.
So this is me.
You can tell a resemblance.
How many of you recognize
this particular symbol?
This is my G+ avatar.
This should shake out anybody
who knows their science fiction
movies.
Anybody?
Go ahead.
It's Tron, indeed.
And even auto-complete
tells us what Tron does.
And so that's kind
of setting the stage.
I also have the
good fortune to work
with some of Google Ventures'
portfolio companies.
So a lot of people
sometimes think
that Google is
extremely insular in how
it approaches what it does.
And I actually have the benefit
of also having some insight
into what smaller
companies are doing.
And that definitely
informs what I'm
going to talk to
you about today.
So the most important
thing to remember
is I'm just one guy up there.
And I stand on the
shoulders of giants.
We have literally hundreds of
people, both in Core security
and Android security and Chrome
security, Gmail security,
working on this stuff.
So I stand before
you here purely
as a representative of a lot
of very hardworking people who
keep our users safe
24/7, all over the world.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is security that we
do on the Google side.
I will talk in some detail about
End-To-End, a Chrome extension
that we released
about three weeks ago.
We'll talk about the
Transparency Report, where
we release data, some of which
is quite security related
and might actually quite
useful to folks on the outside.
We'll also talk about Safe
Browsing, a very large system,
that actively hunts
malice out on the internet
and helps protect our users.
Then we'll go into a little
bit more about things
that you can do as developers,
as companies, how you should,
in our eyes, potentially
think about security and risk,
and how to go about
prioritizing some the decisions
that you make.
And then we'll talk a little
bit more about security
that you as individuals can do.
And finally, we'll move to Q&A.
So in terms of
security that we do,
it's important to start
thinking in terms of scale.
Let's measure a
couple of things.
As you can see at Google,
we have a large number
of very colorful
tubes through which
we pump a great deal of data.
Mary Meeker released
her internet report
about a month ago,
saying that there
are about 2.6 billion
people online today.
Safe Browsing covers over
1.1 billion of those.
So we can confidently
say that we
are protecting about 42% of
the entire online population
of the world, just to give
you a point of reference.
Chrome users number over
750 million 30-day actives.
So they're also protected
by Safe Browsing
and by a lot of the security
features that Chrome brings.
And Gmail has over
425 million users,
and they are protected not
only by Safe Browsing--
and if you use Chrome,
the connection to Gmail
via Chrome-- but they
have anti-spam measures
and a variety of other systems,
including TLS encryption, that
help protect our users.
We also think in
terms of Android.
As Sundar said in the
keynote yesterday,
there are 1 billion 30-day
active Android users.
And a large chunk
of those users have
Verify Apps on their system.
Now, the back end for Verify
Apps is part of Safe Browsing.
So that's a different 1 billion,
a slightly different facet
of how we look at
security and how
we look at protecting our users.
So as I said, occasionally
we are accused of insularism.
I like to think of us as
building lots of bridges.
And the important
part of this is
where our bridges connect
to the outside world.
We're very strong
believers in open standards
and open standards bodies.
We were one of the
first adopters of DKIM.
We use OAuth.
We use OpenID.
We also work with other
parts of the industry.
For example, together
with the Fido Alliance,
we're working on open
interoperable standards
for strong authentication.
And we're also helping fund the
Core Infrastructure Initiative,
which is working to
find and identify
particularly key
pieces of software
or other bits of infrastructure
out there that need
help keeping them secure.
And indeed, economics is
a key part of security.
The reason that criminals
continue to do this
is because it's
profitable for them.
So they have a very
strong profit motive,
a very compelling
financial incentive.
We like to use the money
that we have for good.
So we have a Vulnerability
Rewards Program,
where we pay out,
depending on severity
of exploitable
vulnerability, various--
we pay for bugs that
can be exploited
against Google products.
There's also a separate program
called the Patch Rewards
Program, where we will actually
pay for people to patch
other pieces of
software that are
non-Google pieces of
software, that increase
the security of the
internet at large.
This is a perfect example of
the dynamic nature of security.
A couple of years back,
it was very, very common
to worry exclusively
about things
that could gain root access
onto your local device,
whether it's mobile, or
whether it's desktop or laptop.
These days, the platforms have
become a lot more hardened.
And so a lot of the
interesting information
remains in user land.
So actually rooting a
machine is no longer
necessary to get a lot of
very, very interesting stuff.
And we expect in a
couple of years from now
there will be other things
that we worry about.
We also know that most
mobile platforms today, out
of the box, as
shipped to end users,
are not easily susceptible to
things like drive-by downloads,
which some desktop operating
systems still struggle with.
So the world is
constantly changing.
The stuff that I
tell you about here
today will have
changed in a year
from now, when I give
the update to this.
And that's one of the reasons
that Chrome and Chrome security
works quite the way it does.
We fix bugs.
We update users.
And speed is
absolutely critical.
This is a chart of
how updates happen
across multiple stable
versions of Chrome.
And as you can
see, the transition
from one version to the
next is fairly quick.
When we first
launched auto update,
the user populous
in general was not
unreservedly
enthusiastic about this.
We were considered arrogant.
How was Google to know best when
to update a piece of software?
Except that at the
time, we already
had a fairly good
idea of the fact
that if we could push
updates to people quickly,
we could very, very quickly
eliminate attack surface out
there, and protect
our users better.
Several years later
since we've done this,
auto updates of security patches
have become a best practice,
and not just within Google,
but throughout the industry.
The ability to quickly
deliver security fixes
is now the common denominator.
Sundar also said in
his keynote yesterday
that 93% of Google Play
users are running the most
recent version of
Google Play services,
including the latest
security fixes.
And that's absolutely
critical, and it's
a testament to the fact
that this stuff works.
But it would never
have been accepted
if we would have pushed live
versions of Chrome that somehow
destabilized users' machines.
So from the non-obvious facet
of security-- reliability,
good engineering practices, good
testing practices, things that
make your software not mess
with your users machines--
those are actually
security characteristics
because they engender trust,
and they increase trust.
And when it's time
to absolutely upgrade
your users because if
you don't upgrade them,
they will be
vulnerable, that's when
you need that trust to have them
allow you to actually update.
Now, we also know that
some of our users out there
in the world are targeted.
In the summer of 2011, we
became aware of an attack
on users in Iran.
And the way we
found out about this
is that Chrome started
reporting this error to users.
We have a feature in Chrome
called certificate pinning,
where Chrome is aware of
which certificates Google uses
as part of its HTTPS.
And Chrome in this case
encountered a certificate
claiming to be from Google,
but it wasn't one of ours.
And we started alerting users.
The users then started
blogging about this error.
And we ultimately were able
to discover that a certificate
authority based
in the Netherlands
had been issuing certificates on
behalf of Google, which was not
something that we had authorized
them to do in any way.
And it turns out the
certificate authority
had been compromised
months earlier.
And they had issued
certificates not just for us,
but for a variety
of other companies.
Now, certificate authorities
need to be very carefully run.
And as a result of this and
subsequent publication of all
of the things that we found,
this certificate authority
is actually no more.
You cannot run a certificate
authority that issues random
certificates and nobody notices.
How many of you
recognize this picture?
It's from not that far ago.
So I never thought in
my technology career
that I would see people
spray painting IP addresses
to the sides of buildings
in civil disobedience.
This was really cool.
Now, these IP addresses are
for Google's DNS service.
And this is a picture from
this past March in Turkey,
where the Turkish
government compelled
Turkish ISPs to block Twitter.
And the solution was
start spray painting
the Google DNS IP addresses
to buildings, to bus stops,
and all over the place.
And this is another non-obvious
facet of security and of trust.
People knew that if they could
get their DNS information
from the Google servers,
they would actually
be able to get
through to Twitter.
And this worked until these IP
addresses were blocked as well.
But even just for a couple
of days, this was worthwhile.
But this was really
kind of cool.
We also know, and have been
talking about publicly,
that some of our users are
very carefully targeted.
And since 2012, for
those users where
we determine that they are
the subject of attention
by state-sponsored
actors, we will actually
give them specific
alerts to that effect.
We will also give them a link
that gives them some advice
to very specifically help in
improving their protection
online, because we don't want
their accounts compromised.
We don't want their
machines compromised.
Which brings us to
End-To-End, which
is a Chrome extension
for encryption
that we announced and
shipped the source
code to approximately
three weeks ago.
The way End-To-End works is
that without End-To-End, you're
typing away in Chrome, and
you're creating your mail.
And we know that the connection
between Chrome and Gmail
is encrypted.
We can mandate that.
That is a requirement.
We have control over
this connection.
But once Gmail sends
out that email,
you may or may not get TLS.
It is entirely dependent on
the receiving email server.
We have no control over that.
We will absolutely support
it if the recipient does.
But if the recipient
doesn't, there
is nothing we can do about this.
We certainly have no
control over the connection
between the receiving
email server
and the actual
recipient machine.
So we go from really quite
secure to cloud of uncertainty,
all the way through
to maybe possibly.
With End-To-End installed in
Chrome on the sender's machine,
we know that the message
body is definitely encrypted.
And in this case,
you've also got
encryption of the
connection by TLS.
You know that as it traverses
the internet to the receiving
email server, you will
also have the message
body of this email encrypted.
And we know that the message
will stay encrypted all the way
to the end, to the
recipient, where
they can use any open
PGP-compatible software
to decrypt the message.
Now you might be
thinking, why on earth
would Google do such a thing?
Well, we know that
we have users who
need more protection than
our high common denominator
of security that
we provide today.
And this is our
focus on the user.
This is why we are doing it.
We want to be able to give
tools to the journalists,
to the human rights
workers, to the dissidents
out there who need that
extra bit of security.
And we want to make
these widely available.
So the extension is not
available in the Chrome Web
Store today, because it
is not a best practice
to write a whole bunch
of brand new crypto code
and then unleash
it upon the world.
It needs time to mature.
And so we're going
to take our time.
We're going to
actively encourage
the community to
review our code.
This extension is already part
of our Vulnerability Rewards
program.
So exploitable
vulnerabilities can indeed
get rewarded, financially.
What we'd like the
community to do
is go to our Google code
page, download the software,
and take a look at it.
Tell us about stuff that
we haven't noticed yet.
We have a bunch of stuff
that we know that we still
want to work on before
we feel it's ready.
But we are positively,
absolutely not
going to put it in
the Chrome Web Store
until we think it's ready.
Here's the URL, if you want to
go check it out, g.co/endtoend.
Now, Transparency Report
is also really cool.
We started it in 2010
and have been reporting
on various things that we
are in a unique position
to have the information about.
Last September, for
example, in 2013,
we sued the US
government to be allowed
to report in some detail about
requests for user information
that we received
as part of FISA.
And starting this
March, we were actually
able to start reporting
that information.
We actually spend lawyer
hours suing the US government
in order to be able to
be more transparent.
More recently, we also released
an encryption-related email
report in June, that talks about
how many external parties we
are able to exchange
encrypted email via TLS with.
A year ago, the second
most recent security report
was related to Safe
Browsing and talked
about the view we
have of malware
and of phishing and
some associated stats.
So let's talk about
some of those.
The upper graph
here describes users
who see browser warnings
in terms of how many
of those per week, and it
fluctuates considerably.
But we do pay close
attention to this
because we want to understand
exactly how often people
encounter these
types of warnings.
We also provide warnings
in our search results,
and that's the bottom graph.
One of the more
interesting graphs
is our detection of
sites that host malware,
and we aggregate them per week.
And as you will see, the green
sites are compromised sites.
These are entirely
legitimate sites
that have somehow been
owned by an adversary.
It's that tiny
little blue fraction
that is the actual
attack sites that
have no other purpose other
than to deliver malware.
And so we feel
it's very important
to reach out to all of
these compromised sites
and help them clean it up.
And the mechanism that we use
for that is Webmaster Tools.
So those of you who
have websites today
and have not yet signed up for
Google's Webmaster Tools, which
is a free service, you should
do that as quickly as possible.
That is the way that we
can notify you most quickly
if there is something
wrong with your website.
And we will give you
pointers and assistance
to help clean things up.
We also track things like
how quickly webmasters
respond to such warnings.
And even more interestingly
in many ways--
the recidivism
rate on the bottom.
So if we discover that a site
has a problem and we report it,
and the site cleans it up but is
then re-infected, or otherwise
re compromised, that's something
that we pay close attention to.
How many of you knew that
this data has been out
there for over a year?
How many of you had no idea?
And of those with their
hands raised, how many of you
think this is interesting data?
OK.
So let's talk about
email encryption transit.
As of early June,
approximately 70%
of the messages that Gmail
sends to other providers
are encrypted by TLS.
So we have 30% more to go.
On the inbound, it's only 53%.
Now remember, this
is not something
that is under our control.
We will support TLS encryption
if the other end does.
So it's very helpful to find
ways to provide incentive
for the other end to
participate in this.
And as you can see in the
lower left-hand corner,
there's a Download Data button.
Please use this data.
That's why we're
making it available.
We spend engineering
hours collecting this data
and making it usable
to the outside world.
That's what it's there for.
Please use it.
And if there are any skeptics
out there who are uncertain as
to the value of exposing
this type of data
to the outside world,
you should take a look
at that Comcast curve there.
It's more of a hockey stick.
So within two days
of us releasing
this report and Comcast's
customers tweeting
and emailing quite
vocally to Comcast,
Comcast had turned on TLS
for all of their mail servers
here in the US.
So this kind of stuff does
have a very, very real effect.
More information, lots more
data for you guys to use--
go to
google.com/transparencyreport/.
Now, let's talk about
a Safe Browsing, which
is a system that's
been around since 2007
and has been, in that
time, looking ever more
carefully for various
forms of malware
and of social engineering
and, particularly, phishing.
And we've been
collecting that data
and putting it together
and providing it
as a database that can be
searched locally, but also
as an API that's freely
accessible out there
in the world.
A typical browser
will continually
update its local database
of Safe Browsing data
in order to present an error
or an alert to the user
if they try and surf there,
because we want to even try
to prevent the user
from even contacting
that site in the eventuality
that a mere contact can already
lead to a malware infection.
This is what's
called a drive-by.
Now this is something that we
could have kept for Chrome,
but we actually
didn't feel that it's
in the interest of the
internet as a whole to do so.
And we make this data
widely available.
And as a result, Firefox
uses the Google Safe Browsing
data to protect its users, and
Safari uses our Safe Browsing
data to protect
its users as well.
Now, no developer
conference would
be complete without at least one
announcement of something new.
So at noon today, we push
live the documentation
to Safe Browsing
protocol version 3.
So those of you who are
already using the Safe Browsing
protocol will have some new
stuff to take advantage of.
One of the most
important aspects of this
is that we actually provide
the same amount of data
with a much smaller data size.
We've got approximately
40% to 60% saving.
So you get approximately
2x the protection per bit.
And we want to do
this because we
feel that getting this
information down to the client
device as quickly as possible
is best for everyone.
It's best for us.
It's best for the client device.
If you want to learn more about
the Safe Browsing API and how
you can take advantage of
it to protect your users,
go to
developers.google.com/safe-browsing/.
So let's talk a bit about things
that you can do as developers,
as a company, and how you
might want to think about risk.
So given a shed of
arbitrary color,
how would you go
about protecting it?
Would you put a
padlock on the door?
Or would you spend many
thousands of dollars, or euros,
for a very elaborate
security system?
Well, it depends entirely
on what's inside the shed.
And so whatever risk mitigation
you have in place needs
to be commensurate with
the threat and the risk
if something winds
up going wrong.
When we think about
risks of this nature,
we think about scale.
It's possible to
steal a single laptop.
It's possible to get
a USB device somewhere
onto a USB bus
associated with that.
But that doesn't scale.
That's very targeted.
That's very limited to one.
We worry about the
things that can
affect very, very large
numbers of users very easily.
And that's how phishing works.
That's how a lot of
malware distribution works.
So we focus on the things that
deliver the most protection
to the largest number of users.
We also believe very
strongly in defense in depth.
There is no single
defensive barrier
that you can put up that will
withstand all possible attacks.
So assume that each individual
one of your defense layers
will at some point
fall and that you
need all of them
working together
to make sure that your users
are not adversely affected.
Make sure also that you
don't obsess too much
about one facet of your
overall security architecture.
It's really, really easy
to get completely obsessed
about picking the
right crypto algorithm
and the right key length.
But if your website
is vulnerable
to cross-site scripting,
all the crypto in the world
isn't going to help you, no
matter how correctly it's
implemented.
So think holistically.
Think about the entire system.
Think about how users actually
use your stuff and all
the paths that your
users will take in order
to get at your services.
Do use TLS whenever possible.
And please do get it right.
How many of you were here at
the HTTPS Everywhere session
yesterday in this room?
Well one of the
presenters, Ilya,
has put up a site called
isTLSfastyet, because that's
one of the biggest
criticisms of implementing
TLS-- is oh my gosh,
it'll slow things down.
It actually won't, but
there's an awful lot
of very, very good
information on that website.
You should definitely
check it out.
But much more tactically,
if people try and come
to your site and they
get a big red screen
saying there's something wrong
with the security certificate,
there's plenty of
research that tells us
that you're going to see a drop
in traffic, easily 30% or more.
So please, don't
just implement TLS.
Please get it done because we're
trying to run an internet here.
And we also don't
want you to start
training your users to
ignore security warnings,
because you don't want them
to ignore a warning when
it's extremely real.
So as individuals, there's a
variety of stuff you can do.
Number one most important thing,
don't reuse the same password
across multiple websites.
This is an attack that
scales extremely well.
If an attacker
compromises one website
and they get a
username/password combination,
they're going to
go and try it out
on a whole bunch of other sites.
And if you reuse your password
across multiple sites,
they will probably
be successful.
So please don't.
Once you've taken
care of that, enable
two-factor authentication
wherever possible.
This is the icon for
Google Authenticator.
It's available on
Android and on iOS.
Please enable it for
your Google accounts.
Please encourage your
friends and family
to enable it on
all your accounts.
And if you use
other systems that
have the capability for enabling
two-factor authentication,
please turn it on.
It really does help.
If you see from Chrome, or
any of the other browsers
that support the Safe
Browsing data and use it,
a warning that says phishing
ahead, don't ignore it please.
We have a very good reason
why we put it there.
Our user experience
researchers find
that sometimes users,
particularly nontechnical
users, will say, well, I
come to this site every day.
Clearly this is the anomaly.
This is the mistake, so I'll
just go right through it.
Except that this
super popular site
got exploited and compromised
overnight last night,
precisely because it
was super popular.
So it is actually likelier that
this is a very real warning
and is very actively
trying to protect the user.
So it's unhelpful if users
get trained to ignore them.
Similarly, if you see a message
that says the website ahead
contains malware,
don't keep going.
And for those particularly
stubborn people,
we've actually included the
little international do not
enter symbol before that binary
actually gets downloaded.
Don't ignore this stuff.
We put up there for a reason.
We really do want
to prevent malware
from winding up
on your machines.
And we do want to prevent
you from getting phished.
But this isn't just
a desktop thing.
You may very well see this
error on your Android device.
Please do not continue.
We have a very good reason
for putting up this error
and for trying to prevent
you from installing this app.
Don't ignore it.
So today we've talked
about security that we do.
We've talked about End-To-End,
the Transparency Report
and Safe Browsing, and
stuff that you guys can do.
I'm going to start Q&A
in a couple of moments.
So anybody who has
any questions, please
line up at the mics.
But before then, a quick
anecdote about scale.
In 2005, in March,
there was a drawing
of the Powerball lottery.
And Powerball people are
headquartered in Iowa.
And uncharacteristically
that evening,
they had a disproportionately
large incidence
of winning numbers.
Now, they didn't get all six,
but they got five out of six.
And statistically, it
was completely improbable
that this would happen.
The geographic distribution
was also extremely wide.
It was from the East Coast, all
the way to Idaho and Arizona.
There were also multiples.
It wasn't just one person
here, one person there.
So their first thought
was, their systems have
been compromised, or
there was fraud involved.
Something bad was
clearly going on.
So they put people on
planes over the weekend
because they knew where there
winning tickets had been sold.
And they wanted to be ready
for when the winners showed
up and claimed their winnings.
And when they asked
the winners where
they had gotten the numbers,
the vast majority of them
said that they had gotten
them from a fortune cookie.
And it turns out that
a single fortune cookie
factory in Long
Island City, Queens,
supplied a very significant
number of fortune cookies
all across the country.
So this is a lesson, not just
about the scale of the fortune
cookie business, but
also not to overreact
in the face of a whole bunch
of signals that suggest
to you as a security
practitioner
that clearly something
criminal is going on.
Sometimes people
just play the numbers
on their fortune cookies.
So that's all I've got.
If you have any questions,
that'd be great.
If you could bring
the house lights up.
[APPLAUSE]
Please do submit your feedback.
That's very important to us.
It feeds back directly into the
session planning for next year.
So we'd really like
to hear from you.
I can't believe no
one has a question.
Please go to the mics because
this is being recorded,
and ask your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about End-To-End.
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: As I understand
IT, most of the crypto
is done in JavaScript,
is that right?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI:
That is correct.
AUDIENCE: Any reason
not to have used
Web Crypto to push that
forward quicker to enable it?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: So we have
nothing against Web Crypto.
We use Web Crypto's RNG.
We use a couple of other
things in Web Crypto.
At the moment, Web Crypto has
not settled down completely.
And so I think it
is very safe to say
that we will use Web
Crypto over time.
One of the things though
that was most important to us
is the auditability and the
reviewability of our code.
It is extremely
important that people
be able to trust End-To-End.
And JavaScript is much more
reviewable and much more
auditable a in this context.
So there are a variety of
factors that factored into it.
We also discovered
early on in our research
that there wasn't a
JavaScript crypto library
that we were particularly
comfortable with.
So we also felt it
would be a useful thing
for the world at large to
have a solid JavaScript crypto
library out there.
So it was one of many
motivations for us to do this.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Sir.
AUDIENCE: Google's
turned down some
of their scouring of the
text for mail and, I think,
apps for education
and paid apps,
but since that is rather
prevalent with End-To-End,
are you guys forfeiting
some of your ad revenues
because you won't be able
to get as accurate ads?
And is there fear that
everyone would do this
if it's super easy, since
you're making it a browser
plug-in, which should just be
relatively easy to install?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: It'll be as
easy to install as the Chrome
Web Store lets us at the
time that that happens.
As I said, we're going
to focus on the user.
We know we have
users who require
that additional
level of protection.
And we think it's the right
thing to do to provide that.
So all else will follow.
If that has other
ramifications, we
are perfectly willing
to have those occur.
But at the same time,
I've lived in environments
where the vast, vast majority
of email is encrypted,
and I'm here to tell
you it is not fun.
So you don't actually want,
in terms of usability,
to have a world where
100% of your email
is, in terms of the
message body, encrypted.
We absolutely want a
world with 100% TLS.
And that's one of
the reasons we're
doing what we're doing
with the Transparency
Report and other things.
But things get very,
very complicated
unless you can get whatever
message body encryption
you use truly
pervasive overnight,
and that turns out
to actually be hard.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a way on the UI
to know if TLS was used on
the transport of emails--
for instance, a lock
icon next to an email
address to know that no
one else has easy access
to view this email in transport?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: There is-- it
depends on your mail client.
You could eyeball--
AUDIENCE: Well, let's
say directly in Gmail.
Is there any user
indication that SSL
was used or will be used?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Gmail
does not currently
have any such indication.
And my first inclination
would be look at the headers.
The problem is headers are
not always 100% trustable.
So you could wind
up in a situation
where you report
falsely either way.
Since we don't have full
control over every single hop
along the way, how
much do we actually
believe an entity
that just claims it?
There's some interesting
attack opportunities.
If you want to create a
false sense of security,
awesome way to do it-- somewhere
along the way say, hey,
this has actually
been fully encrypted,
except where it wasn't.
But that MTA is misreporting.
So it's fraught with more
danger then you might suspect.
And one thing that
we're very, very clear
about is we do
not want to create
a false sense of security.
AUDIENCE: So do you
have any recommendations
on how to educate users?
Some things that work
better than other things?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: It depends very
much on the user population.
Humans are a very diverse bunch.
There are many
cultural differences.
linguistic differences.
I don't think that there
is a one size fits all.
One of the things that our user
experience researchers focus on
is, how do we make
the warnings that we
present as effective
as possible?
How do we prevent people
from just clicking through
in the face of something that
we know is a very active threat?
And it turns out
to be quite hard.
So it is an unsolved problem.
I think you have
so much variability
in the human psyche that I'm
doubtful that it will ever
be solved perfectly.
But there are a lot of people
working very, very hard
on this notion of
usable security.
There's a lot of
research going on.
There's an existing
large corpus of research,
but it's far from solved.
Any more questions?
Going once.
Going twice.
OK thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]